hello everyone and welcome to a webinar
we will begin in just a moment thank you
everyone for your patience as we ironed
out some technical details and I
appreciate you you joining us today
Ronald how do you hear me okay I can
hear very well right hear me yes
absolutely
so we're all we're all in the same game
alright so if you would just mind a
letting me know when to advance slides
I'll be helped I'll be able to get us
through this okay let's begin everyone
thank you for joining us and again once
again this session is being recorded and
a recording will be made available as
well as a wrap-up article very shortly
and thank you for joining us hello and
welcome to our webinar today your future
in data science a career outlook for
2020 data scientists are enjoying the
brightest career outlook for the next
decade and many companies are
transforming themselves from traditional
software development specialized errs
into data science companies now how can
you take advantage of this demand so in
this session
Ronald Van Loon the world's top
influencer in data and analytics will
tell us all the data science career
outlook information for 2020 and how you
can go about landing a job as a data
scientist and you of course are invited
join with your own questions
observations to the chat feature of
WebEx so before we get started I just
want you to take a minute to familiarize
with how you can participate so what
will happen is that by default
everyone's microphone is going to be
muted so you can ask a question of Raul
or myself by simply clicking the chat
button that's out that's a speech icon
bubble at the bottom of the page there
and then a chat window will appear and
of course you can in the to field right
select the host and presenter from the
drop-down menu make sure you select host
and presenter and that way Ronald and I
will be able to see your question and
then finally in the chat box once you've
typed your question hit Send and then
we'll be on our way so I am I'm Dan
beavin or your moderator today and it is
my pleasure to introduce you to our
esteemed
Ronald Van Loon now Ronald Van Loon is
one of the foremost thought leaders in
the fields of data science and digital
transformation he was named by
analytical as the world's number one
influencer in data and analytics
automation and the future of the economy
and technology
he's also the number two influencer in
the world an Internet of Things topics
and also artificial intelligence and
digital transformation and of course AI
and education and he was also named the
number three influencer in AI and many
AI related topics in addition to his
popularity as a speaker at worldwide
events he is also an author of a number
of leading big data and data science
websites including data flock data
science central and the Guardian and
he's a director at adverse citement a
leading data analytics company so thank
you very much for joining us Ronald and
thanks for everyone for for
participating as well how are we doing
thank you Dan and thank you for the very
kind introduction
my pleasure it's really great to see so
many people on the webinar because data
Sciences is an incredibly popular topic
and and we're looking forward to hearing
what you have to say on the career
outlook so let's start off by telling us
what is data science and and and what
does it do it may be thoughts with an
analogy to to make it a little bit more
vivid and like a little bit more passive
you know think of a fruit basket that
contains all kinds of different fruit
from numerous different countries where
you can think about from bananas from
Brazil or avocados from California or
Kiwi so of course I'm from New Zealand
and as a chef would you get this fruit
basket and would like to figure out how
to combine all these separate distinct
types of fruit and make really unified
this like like a pie or fruit cake for
example so they need to be able to look
at these different fruits and figure out
what nutritional value they offer and
what flavors stay very good together and
what other ingredients to be added to be
integrated into
they and what the impact is going to be
to a person to eat a diet or in eating
habits or how it affects the current
restaurant menu for example maybe you
can go to the next slide
shall I say next slide if I want to have
a next slide yeah run we'll just say a
move ahead or something like that and
and I'll get the end thanks
so if you look at the data scientists
they have to act in a similar way for
for their business and they have to look
at tons of different disparate types of
data sources and figure out how to
collect how to store how to process but
also how to distribute it and maintain
it in a way that real meaning can be
derived from it so it's similar like
let's say it is cook and they have to
obtain insights so that companies can
act all the information and support
their business codes so a data scientist
need to be able to use the data for the
bigger picture and they need to be able
to look at this from separate stars in
the night sky and see this constellation
which is a similar methodology I think
and there's a lot of different job
descriptions and a lot of different job
titles or for data scientist and which
can be confusing sometimes it's
confusing for me but the end especially
imagine that is computing for many
companies for many directors and lots of
people that are into the main but their
job is to make the current data sources
make them really useful make them flying
and really create new ones and help the
employee and the company to innovate
with data so if you look to a data
scientist there's a model business on
the other hand there are also problem
solvers and you need to be able to
communicate your real communicator and
help with the decision-making so the
data science have to have skills to work
really or large sets of data force and
integrated data set and make something
useful and make something meaningful
let's say with a comparable like with
this cook so sometimes data science have
to think outside the books as well or
don't even think from from a box
perspective and get a little bit more
creative to go to conclusions and that's
why data signs in such a straightforward
job position it's really depending on
you
specific project is depending on your
specific company goals and what you're
going to approach how you're going to
approach it the data and how you're
going to approach the technology and
different tools to achieve your end goal
so you have a lot of choices and all
kinds of different industries all kinds
of companies with also governance
entities they all need data scientist
and not only for helping them to gain
insights from the data but also to make
predictions for more static decision
making next slide please them so a data
scientist tasks or its job function
whatever you want to call it may seem
similar to performing basic business
intelligence but I think there are some
very clear distinctions so if you look
to bi bi is intended for analyzing
specific data and reliable specific
strategies and technologies to offer
past present and predictive views of a
business daily operation the BI uses
structured information and it falls more
under this solidly in the domain of
analytics and it uses a lot of
visualization tools and like dashboard
or like report and that are built on
more standard standard statistics and it
prepares fast and current information to
pinpoint trends if you now look to data
science then it uses both scripted and
unstructured data and this is more based
in science and more in mathematics and
it uses various forms sophisticated
statistical and predictive analysis and
you can think about machinery or AI of
course and it combines both the past and
the current data to arrive these future
predictions
next slide please so what daily life
like look like for a data scientist what
does their job look like if I look at it
it starts with figuring out the problem
it's like looking to a huge file of
butterflies that you tipped off out of
the table from a box and then deciding
where all the edge pieces are and so you
can start the foundation to build on and
then you start adding one piece of piece
at a time to each other and start
building this image to get the big
picture and same is with collecting the
data working with the data to make sure
it's accurate to make
is useful and going through the
analysand lytic process building the
models building the algorithms and then
arriving at the so important and helpful
conclusions that and the results that
you can share with your your management
and with your higher-ups and then you
choose the same type of techniques on
this puzzle and you do it over and over
again so there's many different reasons
why they sign is going to continue to be
really increasing function for eruption
for 2020 it's already there for multiple
years that it's going to say for
multiple years so let's start with some
facts if you look to India for example
it's a major growing energy picture and
primitive analytics market in India is
currently already thirty billion dollars
which is substantial and the ability to
modify the data secure skilled talent is
a top priority for many of the business
leaders in India not only in India but
in any country based and these business
leaders are also competing for the top
talents with the right attractive skill
sets and this is a big initiative but
also a big concern for them right now
and outsourcing is another one
Alton also has been a top driver for
data scientist amount in India and this
is done to increase the next few years
even more so India is a major provider
of data analytics out for some right now
and the AI apartment will really further
accelerate this outsourcing initiative
especially in the areas of cognitive
automation and advanced analytics we're
very specialized knowledge and skills
are necessary so there's a gap between
the supply and demand of data scientists
and everybody was in data science
recognize this and get for the price
often of course so if you look for
example to the US the largest in this
market is the US and there's a need
right now over 150,000 data scientists
and this is according to top list
there's also the global shortage of data
data science skills also in Europe and
Asia but I think us is in advance of the
other countries right now and in these
countries it's about vendors some
thousands of requirements so if you are
company you really need expert tell but
it can be very difficult to
because of the complexity of the data
and each of the company's specific data
practices so if you are data scientist
you have to be able to handle the
technical those are the communication
and also the business aspect of the role
and that's only at the beginning when it
goes through the skill set that you need
so businesses are changing their
perspective of data scientist and want
less generally generalize skills and
they want more and more specialization
the company wants skills specific and
sector specific skills that can help
them innovate and if you don't have the
set of specific skills it's very hard to
support a company with innovation and
with this innovation they want to drive
their description with new technologies
and where once we thought that they
designs is more some kind of open fields
we feel now this really is now narrowing
to this very specific part and you can
compare it with a brick roads that has
different kinds of forms where you have
to choose your your direction and that
we now move into 2020 and as well the
future years after that data sides have
been developed the specialized skills to
be highly specific and highly precise so
think about it what you want to do what
you like what you love and start finding
that direction so this specific fork in
the brick road that you as a data
scientist you need to choose now and
take going where you want to go and
where you could career develops it the
data science has been the number one
position on glass drawer of the best
jobs in America and this is a ready for
four years and that's probably not going
to stop and I'm sure you're heard for
the cystoscope
the sections open in the US or the
unicorn of positions by major
publications last year if we look a
little bit more ahead and we look to
2026 you have the Bureau of Labor the US
Bureau of Labor Statistics and they
predict that in 2026 so around six years
from now it's 11.5 million jobs in data
science and analytics and let's keep guy
dancing so if you look to the US alone
this is the job position availability
and this is going to be mirrored in
other countries as well
u.s. is ahead together with China but
you can expect this time kind of trend
in other countries as well there's also
a real-time analytics so real-time
analytics is playing a role in demand
for data scientist skills as well so you
see the rapidly importantly changing for
tons of different data sources and
demand for very specific skill sets from
the talented data scientist on the other
end you also need a more reduced data
analytics governance and this is
changing right now we see this in Europe
with the GTR so the need for gtp are
needs to be compliant which means that
it needs to have strong data security
standards that are defined and also set
by the data scientists and additionally
you can see that companies that need
exercises that they designed this to
help them connect the data with all the
basic business initiatives in a way that
it really aligns with the importantly
changing data privacy laws and
regulations so these laws advancing in
Europe we have already next version and
we see in 20 20 years also in California
is implementing a similar data privacy
act similar gdpr
so there's likely to be an increase for
data science skills in this state and
well although there is a force in
California already a huge huge team up
it's also interesting to note that
research shows that 94% of data
scientists and graduates have gotten
jobs since 2011 94 percent so you can
feel very comfortable if you're either
moving into depth direction or you are
already data scientist that you have
very good job potential and stay within
this domain as well this indicates how
reliable a career option in data
scientists both now but as well moving
into the future for the coming years so
it's a career path that runs parallel to
all the digital disruption that's on the
horizontal you see this is evolving very
very quickly and it's capable of growing
alongside of the changing landscape of
the technology progress so if we look to
this growth is growth in data science
right now is also connected to other
important factors you can think about
the
protected data increase from IOT or from
social data at the edge I spoke
yesterday last week with somebody from
HP I said who all data in the world that
we have 75% of the data all data
available is at the edge and we are only
collecting our very very minimum part of
this so there is a huge potential and we
hear other advancements in AI and
machine learning technology like these
are really spreading the adoption on use
of the intelligent technologies in more
and more businesses many many companies
now proximity knowing in the eye and
these developments of increasingly
sophisticated computing capabilities to
make the use of accelerating data and
algorithms so we see that all these
broken data all of these new
technologies files and adoptions of
sophisticated technologies increasing
computing capabilities require
highly-skilled
data scientists to manage it so that's a
very nice I think forecast also
accordingly to the data security
confidence index and this was full Jamal
so this wasn't to 2018
they say that 65% of the businesses they
couldn't analyze or categorize all the
data they are stored and this is also a
common problem with many companies so
they cannot handle their current data
that they store so companies are going
to have even more difficult times in
managing all of the data that grow
spontaneously and increased Rifton the
needs and the connection to multiple
data so the data growth will be a major
factor in contributing the ongoing
demand for your data science and more
and more companies are adopting AI and
they were adopting machine learning so
AI specific skill sets are becoming
increasingly important and prominent
across any type of sector also if we
look at IDC they predicted in 2022 that
75% of the enterprises will infusing
intelligent automation into this
technology and process development and
using AI based software to discover
operational and experiential insights to
guide their innovation so this is a
tremendous increase from the users of AI
and if you then look to the chief data
officer from these organizations to
which I often talk to and also senior
executives they're really serious about
a I and going to be focused on getting
this data that their data science needs
needs during 2020 so there's a
tremendous focus on this and
additionally being able to effectively
in using talents Lee this automation is
going to call for a big effort in data
cleansing but also in integration and
offering data management and as its
revolving any data issues in legacy
systems that a data science skill need
to support there's another reason why
they scientist are in such a high demand
is because of the whole data science
process itself is repetitive in nature
so it evolves the input of many
different skill sets and many different
subject matter experts companies want to
be able to speed up and refine this
process so it's more predictable and
they can increase and improve more than
time to value they also want to be able
to constantly and continuously improve
the operator of realization of the data
science so it should all go a smoother
it should go faster and they need to
write skills for it so if we then look
at the different training and different
career path options and I've already
mentioned how the need for more
specialized and more specific data
science skills is becoming increasingly
important for your career so let's get
into this skill that are particularly in
demand those companies are looking for
special skills that range from
analytical and critical thinking also to
machine learning and to natural language
process and skills in software
programming and engineering also quite
popular areas if you look to tellen
specialization and you can think about
it if this is an area for you and being
able to effectively work with earth
structured data also very important
because companies have all kinds of
different data from all different kinds
of variety of sources and input data is
growing tremendously so the neat data
sciences that are able to work with data
using all any number of different type
of tools so all those skills and types
of companies are looking for data
scientists are skills and data analysis
that's basically where you can start one
skill which is really
important which I think many dead
science is still lack but is very
valuable is the communication skill and
it's both verbal and written and as they
decide this you're not going to be very
valuable tested for a business leader if
you're not able to communicate with them
effectively so you have to be able to
connect the business side of the data
signs with the technical and the
scientific side of the Riveter you have
to share your ideas and your goals with
all the type of business users and
leaders in a way that they understand
and that's a skill that's so valuable
that I think your your value increases
multiple tens of percent if you go for
this skill and you also need to be able
to work as a team member and this
communication part helps you with with
this as a data scientist you're first to
have some more creative and imaginative
skills which brings you destroy telling
if you're able to share your insight
with business users and non data
scientist in a way that they can quickly
comprehend it and you're likely to go to
be relying on some more storytelling a
bit capabilities that help you draw some
connection and conclusions in a more
Universal way which helps your your
environment and your other employees to
understand what you mean
so the adaptability and the product
understanding are other important skills
it also drives your curiosity to to
innovation so you need to love your
domain where you're in you need to spend
time as they next to your job in the
domain and if you are loving it you can
drive your innovation because you really
feel the passion and understanding your
business is incredibly valuable in the
new era next slide please
so companies they're always looking for
the data scientist with the specific
skills but also of course with the
certification and instead of data
scientists who can do a little bit of
everything they look for the specialists
so they scientists should focus on for
example one specific field of AI and you
can think about data labeling or you can
think about machine and host
mysticum modeling or parallel computing
if you look to top talent in AI they
should have the skills in ai ai
vacations but now with the new
developments in cloud also in cloud
computing and the fast advancement in
IOT also in IOT and in industrial
robotics or that area which are very
valuable what we see it faulted well is
this deep learning so skills and deep
learning frameworks is becoming more
widely used and is in demand and is the
skills to support your AI innovation
most companies today if I talk to
industry leaders they're investing in
data science gear and it's a necessity
for the businesses to compete and to
survive today and to survive tomorrow if
they don't invest in data science they
basically will be out of business quite
soon and that's in most of the industry
so the belly really generates from
insights to help companies do
personalized user experiences for both
the customer but also for the employee
it's also a valuable skill and many of
you probably know that how important
personalization is and interactions you
have it in your personal business you
want to have a personal treatment
everything is personalization
personalized right now and it's also
happening now step by step in B to B so
personalization is going to be an
ongoing business objective moving into
the future as well
if you look at the data scientist it's
constantly in demand and if we talk
about sectors it's in every sector every
fields of business or whatever interests
you happen to be you're probably going
to find corresponding needs for data
scientists in that domain so look at
what you like what you love and finds
the companies that fit with you just
keep it in your perspective if you want
to look for the top industries then you
can think about industries like
healthcare you can think about
pharmaceutical telecommunication energy
in automotive these are five industries
that are really advancing and moving
forward and at the highest needs in data
scientists right now so depending on
your area of interest and your skill
specialization data scientists need to
have a lot of career options available I
think so if we look at the career path
development it happens during your
career based upon your skills based upon
your interests based upon your
experience and you naturally gain all
different kinds of domain
knowledge and specialized skills as you
are immersed in your everyday practicing
if you like your practice you gain
experience quite quickly and this can
help you better understand and learn to
identify and work around all the
challenges that you have in data science
I I think myself so this brings us to
death to the next topic so where and how
do you want to start but now you're
probably wondering where and how you
just want to start your education and
your career journey in data science
that's probably why you join this this
webinar as well so for those who are
already already practicing data
scientist this can help you further to
improve your career and your ongoing
education I want to add pursuing ongoing
education and skills in this field it's
going to be a huge asset because the
fountains are so quickly
you can't stop but the fields evolved so
far and there's all the new technology
and all the new techniques if you're not
keeping up yourself informed and fresh
it all the time you're going to find
your relevancy and your contribution to
your job role really at risk quite
quickly already so you might find that
you naturally begin to develop a certain
specialization and should continue to be
immersed in a specific data science of
data application role or specific type
of everyday tasks and I seeded with more
and more companies that just hire a
Bachelor and they say let's find out
where you fit let's find out what you
like and develop the skills step by step
after you obtain an undergraduate degree
you may want to look into applying for
an internship where you can find a
special area of interested guys your
advanced education and guides you in
your professional career path so what I
see is still a lot of things science is
fine that getting advanced degrees like
a master's degree in specific field of
data science ends up directing their
specialization towards a very specific
industry or very specific field and if
you're gaining in the phone's degree
isn't an option for you or doesn't
interest you you don't like it but you
still want to focus on specialization
through educational resources you can
earn a bachelor's degree for tumbling in
data science and then extend your
specialization taking
or kind of supplemental courses for
example in programming languages or in
data warehousing function many will see
the data signs as a cross-disciplinary
fields and this can be an advantage
because there's so much room for the
specialization so there are specific
areas of Education to focus as you
consider your future career outlook as a
data scientist and then you can think
for example of big data big data are
actually management that's really
foundation every company to do analytics
and to do advanced analytics so based on
the solid foundation companies can do
their analytics to provide insights and
to approve their products and services
but also their business model and this
is the core why they're doing this many
things their data properly on enterprise
level gives companies a really required
foundation and therefore is the skill
that is very valuable for data
scientists so you can never look into
educational courses in big data but also
in data mining or in predictive model
building but also in Hadoop or in SPARC
the next area you can think about bi and
data science we're having sought
understanding and skills in bi or their
science will give you a really good
foundation to perform application
analysis or data modeling centralized
data warehousing we can think about
certification and data management's bi
reporting or bi development and there's
several certifications that are relevant
for this and you can think about
machinery or crystallization of
probability and statistics the next one
we were talking about it already
it's machine during nai so machine
learning in AI is the domain that
evolves very very rapidly right now
every technology company is focused on
it as a very high number one or number
two priority and education is a must to
stay up to date with the latest advances
and technological methodologies don't
stop have a look into professional
certifications like their linguistic
programming and natural language
processing deep learning and predictive
analytics Forbes on enterprise cloud
platforms it's the last new trends we
see this data management analytics and
machine learning and AI they become all
part of the enterprise cloud in
structure whether it's unfriend whether
its clout at customer or whether it's
cloud now it's all under the cloud a
domain and it's all integrated and this
moves quite quickly forward it becomes
much easier now to set up and deploy an
end-to-end infrastructure an enterprise
level but it still needs a scientist to
understand how all the applications
deliver one total solution if you look
at certification the domain you can
think about cloud platform an
infrastructure or cloud development or
cloud architect I think we won't slide
behind and go to the next slide so how
to improve your talents to meet the
skills map develop basically literacy
and programming skills with hands-on
training
don't try everything by education just
start doing it and applied experience is
just as important as the education is
knowing but also it's doing and if you
want as much experience as you can get
just go out there and start doing it
also you need to stay on top of all the
industry trends and innovations in the
domain that you like so you are aware of
changes in your field and you adjust
your ongoing training and education
along with these new types of trends on
your ends supplemental resources to help
you practice all your skills and you can
think for support as you further your
education or your career in two years
and you can check out some external
professional resources like the data
Science Association and this is a
nonprofit organization that helps you
promote ethical behavior and diversity
in this profession and acting ethical in
a diverse manner with data is becoming
more and more important than the focus
from many different companies and this
features a wide catalogue and library of
helpful materials that they have for
data scientists another one is also base
I boot camp for Tom you have data
science dojo and the New York data
science Academy as all those want
engagement in the industry outside of
the education or the certification next
slide please
so this brings us a little bit more into
the future
so moving towards the future of data
science Oh
if we look to the future companies need
to innovate and problem-solve much
faster and more efficiently so
competition for better more specialized
stem talent and more specialized will be
really authorized as companies trying to
get ahead of the game and take advantage
of the new technologies and this
competition between all the companies
for the best talent is growing and
growing which is good for all the data
scientists out there but also if you
look the future workspaces are going to
have a much more specialized source of
value generation called abuse as well so
the large contributors to this value are
going to be the data scientists and the
craftsmen so there's a new type of trend
organizations will be changing their
entire hiring process and talent
structure to accommodate the needs for
the specialized talent and it can be
either the craftsman or the data
scientist and where it's now going this
talent structure for a traditional
hierarchical
paramedical shape so you have the CEO
you have the vice president you have the
director you have the manager and then
you have the operation this is going to
change this is going to change in what
they call more or roll the shape where
you have the cross room and the data
scientists centrally in an organization
and define all the new products all the
new suits and the innovation and this is
supported by AI to automate or
repetitive type of thoughts so
organizations will continue to adopting
these more advanced technology tools
that require a more narrow and more
specialized fields of talent you can
think about cloud computing and edge
computing is becoming increasingly
beneficial for companies I was talking
about this already
that is as computing that 75% of the
data available worldwide is at the end
we only approaching I think they're 5 or
10% and these companies they need done
to handle both the current and the
future demands of this AI technologies
and in fact
54% of all the decision makers who are
using now this edge computing claims
that the ability to manage the future
demands very high technology like this
edge computing that's going to be the
one of the biggest advance and
53% of the global data analytics
decision-makers have also adopted or are
in the process of implementing and
expanding and creating importation some
form of AI 53% already and it was I
think last year 15% so this is growing
tremendously they design job roles and
titles are going to be highly specific
to match the need for they specialized
talents and new job roles and you can
think of for Tablas data size leaders or
you have translators or you they're
already going to come over and you see
new new titles and new job roles popping
up step-by-step as the market that
founders so it's likely that all these
new doc titles immerse as we move into
the future and the talent and the skills
become even more focused around the
specific capabilities around a specific
game domains are still many times right
now and but it's really something that
we see as it as a big trend so if you
look to the professionals who are
already immersed in the industry they're
finding they're becoming becoming
challenges across all this related
skills and they're altering their hunt
for the talent and they're altering the
move to the future so if you look to the
identity data scientist they really side
all the time this lack of relevant
skills and talents as a key internal
roadblock for their success which is
good for the data science role but
therefore for the companies and data
analytic skills their names as for CEOs
as the most in-demand skill and this is
according to regard the server brain but
increasing importance of data analytics
is causing organization to really
reshape and rethink their approach to
specific data analytics talent roles if
they move to the future if they want to
compete they need to have these skills
they need to have this talent and right
now some key rules the card has
mentioned for data analytics and data
science for example data engineers but
also must data management program
managers or data ethics ethics or
data-driven facilitators and moving into
this future the new rules are emerging
to add value to the business you can
think about things like
with business domain expert but also
data sourcing managers
I was talking to revolute and they were
adding 350 sources of data for three
months to their current structure 350 so
sorting the data becomes also very
important if we look to the data epic
sis they will continuously be very
critical of how companies treat and use
the data it should be ethical and
particularly installation about AI
ethics we see them evolving an important
point of interest and all of people and
society think that data and AI should be
used
ethically and which is really the
foundation to let AI survive over the
next seven years
emerging user interfaces of NLP of
gesture and computer vision they're
going to be embedded in every kind of
product and device and also needs they
scientist for this and advancement in
innovation in AI the shifting this
future talent to work mastering this new
type of skill so they need to be able to
offer your data insights they need to be
able to apply technology in different
scenarios but also the data scientist
need to be with form Civ to dynamic
changes and customized demands and
maintain all the business stands across
various different platforms there's
something I hear a lot of interest and
concern about is what is the increasing
automation of data science tasks and the
automated data science tools means for
the future of data scientists and I
think you can generalize it and look at
how AI is evolving right now AI is
augmenting all different kinds of
journals and I think it's the same for
the data scientists so companies are
facing data size challenges and which is
leading to a growing adoption of
automation of data science tools and
tasks or there's a shortage for trying
to automate it and they design projects
are really time consuming them also may
take too long to deliver value and
impact to companies and domain knowledge
and expertise from dead scientist is
very hard to get by companies and it's
very hard to retain because of the skill
shortage and the high demand of
so the heavy dependency on this and a
very small pool of talents or an
experienced people makes it very hard
but also gets quite some pressure on
this automation automated data science
can analyze all this massive amount of
data quickly and it's typically used
during the machine learning modeling
traces right now it's also used to
reduce some of the heavy lifting and
tedium from the data science process
automation can also be used to automate
important but very time-consuming tasks
occur when developing and optimizing
your AI so this can allow their
scientist to work with more high-impact
use cases and take more exploratory
projects and speed up the time to
results and I see this in every job role
and I think they designed this data
scientist is not an exception but
ideally automated data science will or
when data scientists and will help them
save time or performance all this
tedious and manual type of tasks and
allow them to do smarter more more
things with intuitive tools and this I
think will change the nature of the jobs
as well so the specific roles and
specific tasks are going to define my
more responsibility and more value
driven impact and also communication is
really a core skill in in this part so
there's going to be a strong need for
mathematical data science skills it's
going to be in need for knowledge in
this domain and ensure that the
automated decisions that are being
generated accurate and they should be of
high quality because a lot of items are
depending on this if you look to
automate the data science tools they
really have the potential to be a great
asset for data scientists so don't be
afraid of it embrace it and open up new
opportunities for creating value and
creating value for yourself but also for
your employer I think it's just like
with any type of form AI in general when
used responsibly and ethically automated
designs will be really a tool that can
help and support also data scientist so
if we look to
the rapper and we see marked evolution
as we move now into 2020 and the next
coming years after and there's going to
be this high demand for data scientists
it's step by step increasing in 2020 and
years after but there's more and more
need for this highly specific highly
specialized skill set so think about
what your direction will be if you take
a junction on your career run as you
look into shaping your education and
your knowledge base focus on with fine
tuning this sector specific and this
domain specific knowledge think about
new rules that are going to be emerging
so having a specialized perspective from
your experience and think about skills
that you can build in data ethics this
is going to be especially attractive to
companies in the coming years and if we
look a little bit further ahead the
future out of data science there's a
need for more narrow specific data
science skills and less for the
generalization specialization
specialists so think of that brick road
that we talked about earlier as you
delve into your education in your career
and you begin to define the type of
specialization and skills that you want
to master to bring value for your
employee and to bring value to your joy
in your in your job we saw also that the
job titles and the roles they're going
to reflect these type of specialized
skill sets so you will see new job roles
popping up more and more for companies
that's looking for more for this
specific specific domain knowledge and
specific skills and automated data
science tasks as we just discussed and
the tools they're going to be a factor
and how many data scientists approach
their projects and how they approach
their job roles then short words about
education and certification I really
truly believe that it's very important
for data scientists to get the right
degrees and the right certification and
not only jump start to their career but
really to advance them so remember that
domain expertise and experience is
really useful and helpful for many
companies but this can be learned over
time as you immerse in practice and of
course course advisor for simpler and
civilians a very very valuable resource
for
day but also for your tomorrows state
assign is to shape their education to
shape the ongoing learning in the career
path thank you for for listening and
apology for for the short delay in the
evening and then maybe there are some
questions hi Ron oh yes absolutely there
are quite a few questions here let me
start off by we have one person who's
asking about their future because he
says that he's having almost 13 years of
experience and but no experience in
programming how do you see the future
professionals like me in the field of
data science or AI and m/l without
starting all over again
so he has experience in idea no
experiences he says he doesn't specify
let's see I have good Excel analytic
skills and see myself as a problem
solver and have moderate presentation
skills and looking for taking a leap of
my career so it looks like he may not
have any programming skills but wants to
see where someone without a background
in programming can can get a start in
trying to get a foot in into either the
education or career like this so what I
see with multiple companies they require
a bachelor's degree so that's the
foundation in the domain and so if you
like the domain you have some knowledge
about it that's I think quite important
and some good or even excellent
analytical and learning remarkable to
see that the bachelor's degree which can
be any degree I even talked to companies
that have people that then studied
geography or historical they went into
data science so it's more to have the
skills then let's say the background and
then you can educate and you can build
experience with one hand SQL for sample
this revolute every person within
revolute revolute is one of the
disruptors in the financial industry
every person in their company either
know or learn SQL that's the foundation
how they start and they let's say make
up data available for everybody and this
is how you get a card as well if you
have interesting is start with SQL start
with your experience and knowledge into
relation
databases may be expanded with
programming skills like our of pipes and
this is how you can can start and start
working within your company our access
to the data if you look more is to a
specific role you can think from the
perspective as a data analyst or you can
call it a junior data scientist but I
think data analyst is a nice step to
start and understand learning and
analyzing data if you want to move
further you can start with master degree
or you can go in this specialized
direction what we're talking about can
think about labeling of big data or seen
earning I think these are next step that
you can move into and I think if you go
into this direction and but what's
important is to reach out to expand your
network and start talking to recruiters
and start explaining what you want and
what you're looking what you're looking
for
look at sites where you can either do
some assignments or just start with this
be doing a free and assignment for free
just get start I think that's the most
important part to move into this
direction yeah the background yeah as I
said bachelor could be sufficient great
so how much statistics do we learn need
to learn if we're getting into data
science the depends where where you
basically start if you start a good
foundation of statistics I think is very
important because more say areas that
would be very important like mathematics
like analytics like data visualization
about some software and engineering and
some programming skills whether it's C++
have some economic background software
development so it's different type of
areas that touch the fields of data
scientist but statistics is some kind of
foundation but again here if you haven't
background in it dive into it and start
doing courses next to your job and
educate in the domain that you like in
the domain what you feel happy with just
yes sometimes some part of let's say a
route doesn't feel comfortable don't try
to push yourself in because there many
different
junctions you can take and just find the
right Junction and if statistics is not
the right Junction for you just look for
different type of rules okay great so a
bill has question as a first graduate if
I can't find a job or internship in data
science what should i do how do we move
forward yeah so come on and make
yourself build some kind of CV reaching
out experience your network that's one
part but also go to sizes Cagle start
doing assignments just start working on
it prove yourself that you develop your
skills and keep on reaching out to
people ask them for either an assignment
or ask them to help asking for data sets
and this way at the certain moment
people will ask you and provide it to
you if you don't know anybody start
reaching out via social media you need
to be proactive and if you just sit and
wait it's not going to happen
great so I have another question here
can you please specify a relevant
certification to data visualization and
as many we have to blow and we have
sauce we have all different kinds of
tools available in the market and I
think over here look as well M is which
type of tools are they using within your
company start with D type of tools if
they are not using tools look to the
list of most used tools but I expect the
different companies have some kind of
data visualization tools and start with
that tool because if you understand one
it's most likely that you can quite
easily switch in case you have to switch
to another that's too great another
question here is somebody has a long
career in finance for example it's got
the training and they get a
certification how are companies okay
with people who switch mid-career from a
non-technical field or they're looking
for people that have been technical
their whole careers so this person
trying to switch from non-technical to
data science is that going to hold them
back no I think it's the opposite
because domain expertise becomes in the
end as important as the data science
skills that you
so if you want to switch and I think
anyhow it's good to step into it because
every company is going to be data-driven
and you need to understand basic skills
all the basic data science skills but if
you want to switch if you have a
bachelor degree if you have certain
domain knowledge if you are enthusiastic
about a certain domain companies love it
because there's a lack and if you have
people that really obsessed about it and
want to study next to the job it is you
can learn it it's not it's not magic its
science so you can learn it step by step
domain expertise is harder and
experience is harder to gain especially
in the financial industry
if domain expertise you need to be in
the domain and the domain is changing so
fast so it's it's hard to buy that so I
think the more people that take this
type of career change will be valuable
for the industry and definitely
companies are very open for this to give
them a chance and give them certain
roots and possibility within an
organization yeah that's a collision
that's great advice with someone else
that is a experienced professional
working in data warehousing and they
have experience for six years and listen
to the challenges that they can trying
to understand this question here let's
see what are their challenges of a
transition to the role of data
scientists and what will recruiters
expect and so I think you just pretty
much answer that question I mean having
a background in your in whatever field
of domain you have even if it's not
related to data science like I said data
science could you can learn but people
really value the experience you bring
outside of it that you can't get just
from any course there's no a to be
predefined career off as they design
this you're a problem solver and there's
a lot of time no clear path for it so
you have to move forward and it's not
always from A to B to C so you're going
to have to approach many different
projects with an open mind and
willingness to try outside of the book
solutions
that I think may contradict with what
you have learned and you've done in the
past and that's the I think the route
you should go and be open-minded right
now we have a lot of people saying that
how do we land an entry-level role in
data science or even a data science job
or internship because it seems that all
roles expect some years of experience
how can you get around that yeah so to
get started is one end start with some
courses and start with some sights like
giggling and do some projects and
document these projects show what you
have done so how you have approached on
reaching out as I said there is yes
there is a lot of demand but what he
wants to have not sure if it's in and
hing this expression a shape with with
five legs that I translated footage but
they want a person and this ideal person
is not there and that's why I wanting to
see all this specialization in different
types of skills and with and on the
other hand yes there is this let's say
shortage but you need to do it yourself
you need to build your career yourself
and reaching out so it's doing it being
proactive and the best way I think is if
you can get into a company that is
data-driven and that it has a nice brand
and even if you have to start for free
or as an internship that's the ideal
route with if you don't succeed don't
give up and start practicing yourself
but document it and make your CV your
curriculum vitae clear what you have
done and how you've done it and your
interest in this domain that you're
interested in in data science that
you're interested in analytics that
you're passionate about it and we step
it every start this is difficult but
somewhere is there is there any way to
integrate cybersecurity and data science
together or is that too big of a
crossover so a part of cybersecurity is
data science is supervised unsupervised
learning it's all kinds of detection of
a text cybersecurity attacks so there is
a part related and on the other hands
everywhere you work with data you are
to security you are related to
governance you are related to ethics and
so everything what you do relates to
this topic you can't go around it you
need take them into consideration and if
you really would like to be
they specialize yourself data science in
cybersecurity yeah then you need to be a
farm starting because this domain is
quite advanced if you look into the
world into the financial world
especially over there with security it's
false and region wise false the crooks
are as false as well and they advance
every two three weeks new methodologies
and you must be able to detect this
spoken frequently to people from
financial industry in the say if
something new pops up we have around
seven days to catch up which means that
they have the best experts in the
industry working on this and for them
it's the critical foundation of trust in
the financial system wait let's see what
little configuration of a laptop do data
scientists lead and then that's kind of
specific but the big investment in
equipment in order to be a data
scientist to be honest I'm not too much
involved in my computers and equipment
and so I have people providing me then
so I'm sorry I cannot help with ok ok
great ok cool let's move on we've we've
already have time for one more question
here one or two more questions and what
are the opportunities available for data
scientists outside of the job market and
data science do companies ever give
their datasets the data scientists for
them to work with what are the
challenges that data scientists these
are lots of one person asking lots of
questions here but let's stick with
those first two things like what do you
do have to do it sounds like they're
asking is there like a freelance data
scientist opportunity out there where
people will share their data sets with
what's outsiders rather than having to
hire them I'm not sure if I fully
understand question okay officer
companies one would like to hire you do
companies ever give their data sets to
data scientists for them to work with
meaning so do you have to work at a
company debated to be a
data scientist or can you be a
contractor yeah you can be a contractor
and as a contractor you probably have to
hand over the work IP from it from your
work definitely as a contractor yes tons
of work if you're good you get it get a
job and you get work and you get paid
well and so the contractual relationship
with companies I think both and what you
do see is that contractors freelancers
they most of the time are more
experienced now they know their value
they know they can get jobs easily so
they say I can freelancer you can hire
me and you for hiring me I go to the
next next job so they're confident about
their skills yeah what sort of a what
courses do you recommend for beginners
like if you're just starting out what
would be the first type of course you
take yeah I think it's data analytics
it's starting very simple maybe with
some data visualization type of courses
if you don't have any skills no
background because if you start in data
visualization you understand the reason
why you analyze data the value of data
and let's say the hard part of the whole
data management and the science behind
it is done by other people and so this
is an easy way to start and what you see
as well is that these type of tools
augment they use more and more so it's
both I think educate yourself on one
hand and on the other hand provide two
results great okay well thank you well
that's all the time we have for now but
I just want to say thanks again to
Ronald Van Loon for joining us today now
for all those who registered through
WebEx please keep an eye out for a
follow up email in a couple of weeks or
so oh that will contain a recording of
this webinar and the video and the
slides and it will also have a written
wrap-up of the webinar so you're going
to read it rather than watching the
whole thing so remember to visit simply
learn comm for more information on
learning all about best practices and
getting certified in data science and if
you have any further questions that did
not get addressed during today's
presentation please feel free
to tweet us at simply learn and we will
get back to you so Thank You Ronald it's
a pleasure to speak to you again
and I'm sure lots of people are better
off for having for this great webinar
thank you for having me and enjoy your
day great thank you
bye bye everyone
[Music]